[Musica]
bello a tutti ragazzi e per tutte questo
nuovo video io sono un po vj e oggi
siamo su sega takai spero che si
pronunci così bello oddio che cosa [ __ ]
e tipo mesi alla fanta allora venite un
indie horror che mi avete consigliato
fantastico visto degli screen veramente
vi ringrazio per avermi consigliato
consigliatemi sempre giochi del genere
perché lì vado sempre a giocare va bene
comunque da quei pochi bello ciao
bongiorno ea si apre sta roba pensavo
non si aprisse pensavo di essere al
sicuro quindi poi anche chiuderti grazie
puoi chiuderti e io non volevo di store
scherzavo non prendertela che scherzavo
speriamo non si incazzi che comunque
vada italy screen che ho visto
praticamente sembra una fusione tra
svendere amnesia c'è una fusione perché
mi pare che devi trovare nelle pagine da
quel che ho visto negli screen e poi c'è
la torcia quindi sembra sembra veramente
amnesia però devi trovare pagine quindi
sembra una figata assurda poi
l'ambientazione mi piace mi piace perché
so già che mi prenderò dei colpi e devo
ringraziare chi mi ha consigliato gioco
vabbè andiamo avanti e ci sono delle
frecce fantastico sembra una abitazione
di quelle tipo dei ninja in giappone e
non capisco perché ci sono delle frecce
a terra ma non importa noi andiamo
avanti a darci una scala di qua penso
che porti di nuovo piano di sotto
affermazione da einstein cazzo le scale
portano al piano di sotto wow proprio
non ci sarei mai arrivato
è una questione torna indietro che mi
sto già perdendo non vedo una mazza
vabbè allora aspettate un attimo fermi
calmi calmi tutte devo andare di qua
perfetto di quando ce l'ho ancora andato
bene allora c'è qualcosa qui una pagina
bene la prima faceless silhouette non
chiedetevi che cosa vuol dire ma
prendiamo la pagina allora andiamo
avanti
uno su otto bene e adesso mi devo
apparire qualcuno che buongiorno
non penso sia lei il nemico verranno
perché io l'avevo chiesto gentilmente di
stare lì dentro perché poi raga sembra
molto strano perché sica anche ce ne
sono due di spuntano ovunque
quanti ce ne sono c'è farsi complice
anche la cosa brutta la cosa macabra è
che si confondono col muro c'è quindi lo
sembra non si vedono
vabbè comunque andiamo avanti qua c'ero
già stato sì non vedo nulla perché non
vedo niente
che razza di stato raga sto andando a
tentoni non vedo nulla e hanno acqua ce
l'ho ce l'ho già passato cos'è cos'è
aiuto aiuto cos'è raga non vedo nulla ce
lo slider perché parto cosa non sto
vedendo cos'è non vedo nulla via via via
via perché aiuta a io la finestra
raga qualcuno mi sta sopra via di qua
via aiuto ragazzo aiutatevi c'è qualcuno
da gioco c'è qualcuno che tentava di
prendermi non so chi raga non mi piace
suo gioco perché se mi spunta qualcuno
davanti in un'ambientazione del genere
vi giuro che tiro un urlo assurdo va beh
devo trovare era che non ho capito bene
qual è lo scopo di sta roba cosa devo
fare o trovare altre pagine l'ho trovata
una su otto
ok ok c'è qualcuno ragazzi non vedo
niente cos'è cos'è e cosa sta cosa
succede fermi calmi tutte tirate una
facciata al muro perché non vedo nulla
cazzo cos'era fermi che succede andiamo
di sopra ragazze già che youtube quando
carichi vi do list di oscura un casino
cioè io odio già di miano vedo una mazza
voi non so che cosa state vedendo spero
che si veda qualcosa comunque va bene e
andiamo avanti bene la torcia la tira
giù lui da solo cioè non serve va bene
allora tienila giu fa quello che vuoi
cos'è ho trovato uno scrigno ho trovato
anche una chiave tra l'altro bene una
chiave fantastico sono passi avanti
perché ci sono delle frecce sul muro sta
cosa non mi piace verda entrò nello
scrigno ragazzo e gli otto c'è quel
commercio non guardano non guardo vado
vado avanti così tipo che sono mimì che
cazzo laga cos'è agli 8 e lo splendore
l'airc bene fanta 1 su 1 su 8 fantastico
premi e vai riproviamoci la camicia che
mi sento fortissimo sto gioco
la camusso non ho mai fatto così schifo
in un videogame tipo slider
vabbè troviamo all 8 pagine alla ragazzi
stavolta partiamo come si deve allora
sono partito fuori è un altro posto
questo non glielo partito di qua prima
si porta in posti diversi benissimo già
partiamo fuori già ci vedo di più di
prima quindi è un bene
va beh noi andiamo avanti non so se ci
sono tattica forse votare adesso vedo di
più come prima
prima la lanterna era made in china
adesso ci vedo va beh allora qua c'è
qualcosa non voglio trovare la prima
pagina perché poi appare lo slider
maledizione dove trovarle cos'è c'è un
armadio e tipo quello di the grudge e mi
chiudo dea ci si può chiudere dentro che
figura che allora sta roba tengo aperta
non si sa mai che mi serve poi cos'è
raga cos'è quella roba rosta cosa sono
degli occhi hanno cos'è sono che cazzo
non capisco ragazzi o dio
oddio è una fine cosa cazzo ecco quanto
è grosso sto posto ma cos'è una pagina
che ho trovato una pagina la prendo in
the wind of shadow nella finestra
un'ombra benissimo allora prendiamo sta
roba alla finestra un'ombra un cazzo non
voglio provare l'ombra nelle finestre
sinceramente va bene buongiorno e tu non
ti stai confondendo con col muro però
vabbè quadro è più bello che io abbia
mai visto in vita mia fantastico un
milione te lo compro hai fatto tu
veramente sei un artista fantastico dove
si aprono le porte anche prima non avevo
capito dall'acqua c'è sempre l'altra
ho sentito il rumore bruttissimo non mi
è piaciuto per niente mi sto pagando
addosso che la metà basta
ma va bene andiamo avanti così c'è una
grata spero noi che speriamo che regga
sta roba non sia avremmo trovato una
chiave servirà for a qualcosa ma c'è il
menu
sono un [ __ ] genio ho premuto il
tasto ex che mi è uscito dal gioco devo
ripartire fan cos'è sta roba
siamo partiti raga in un'altra zona
ancora ma perché ma quando il grosso suo
posto e o ritrovare i punti di prima
raga è troppo grosso suo posto ci son
partito in tre punti diversi
ma forse l'ha cambiata la cambia la
mappa cambio nivard in the woods nel
bosco si ci manca solo questo dicevo
raga forse la mappa cambia ogni volta
che cary inizio gioco forse perché c'è
non è possibile che di tutti i tre punti
che dove ho giocato non ne riconosca
nemmeno uno cioè non mi sei riuscito a
ricollegare nemmeno a uno quasi una
porta benissimo e chiuso anche questa
acqua forse ce l'ho passato non ce l'ha
passato cazzate ha invece si è sotto
renato davvero prima abbiamo ricongiunto
un punto fontana ok bene merda merda
merda merda
torniamo indietro chiudi la porta
ok benissimo anche se cosa e nuova nello
svendere non c'è mai stata
cioè che tipo poi chiudergli la porta in
faccia e quindi lui non ti può
raggiungere spero è ovviamente spero due
pagine e ce lo slider merda fatto il
giro siamo a due
è un record ragazzi un record fantastico
io andrei di sopra perché mi sto calando
di brutto che sono due pagine bene si
apre prima saprete questa che prima non
si aprivano sto posto il labirinto
perché adesso le porte si aprono tutte
prima non sapremo una mazza vabbè c'è
qualcosa di qua cos'è perché hai tirato
giù la alterna ti pesa al braccio
ragazzi siamo a 2 a 2 su 8 ma si può
oddio dove cazzo sono caduto buongiorno
è uno stupro di massa sono caduti una
gang bang è mimistro mi stuprano credo
deve uscire di qua perché dio esco
ragazzi grazie mille dell'offerta ma io
esco bene ragazzi guardate anche dove
mettere i piedi perché è assurdo
fatemi che le foto dove la torcia
maledizione sta cazzo di nahan terra che
non esce va bene allora andiamo avanti
è assurdo come posto ma come cazzo fanno
a concepire una cosa del genere
dove sono sono sono fuori sono dove
cazzo sono finito raga a sono perfetto
solo fuori allora ci siamo ricongiunti
di nuovo con tutti i tre punti
oddio no fermo dove tre k 9 appreso la
lezione
no non mi dire che peso morto non mi
dire che non sono morto su ancora vivo
sto ancora vivo scappa scappa scappa
entro dentro chiude o si è aperta una
poco a una porta che si apre non ci
posso credere che evento forse è
possibile che qui qualcosa di nuovo ci
trova dato che prima non aveva aperto la
porta buongiorno mi fa passare
cortesemente non grazie mille lei è
molto maleducato nessuno gli ha mai
detto ed è perfetto per c'è
qualcos'altro un'altra porta bene stiamo
aprendo poi sono progressi la capa che
prima non aveva aperto una mazza magari
se trova un'altra pagina mi fate
contentino per che sia ma due ancora 2
ecc è chiusa anno non è chiuso perfetto
aperto non perché se non impossibile è
un labirinto dove sono finito riker lab
sono finito in un labirinto come se non
bastasse c'è anche lo slang va bene
ragazzi allora è impossibile dove cazzo
sto guardando agli 8 dove sono
adrid perfetto aldo acceso cos'è questa
è una forma riportate buongiorno c'è
anche lei vedo che si nasconde e
malandrino fa bene è amica dove si
trovano le pagine no perché qui sono
ancora due brutti stronzi
mi batterò le troverò prima hero è
un'altra porta fantasma siamo usciti
siamo usciti fuori miracolo assurdo
siamo fuori raga non è che sono più
allegro di essere fuori sinceramente
perché quasi più tetro fuori che dentro
ma vabbè almeno siamo fuori almeno vedo
dove cammino e non rischio di sbattere
contro un armadio quindi va beh ci siamo
e ce n'è un'altra parte della casa che
non avevo visto dove è la nostra è
ovunque per l'affare anche fuori bene
allora ci seguirà fino in capo al mondo
ecco ora che la vedo la parte nuova
maledizione fi luce poco accordo ci sono
pagine sugli alberi verranno perché ci
manca solo questo fa misto piacere entra
dalla finestra che ci puoi entrare
perché non ci posso credere che non
l'hanno fatto la pasqua la porta non si
apre
raga mi sto per vi giuro che non sto
capendo dove si va beh chiuso anche no
no no ecco che torna indietro merda non
c'è perfetta
[ __ ] è impossibile ma per haga è
stato impossibile comunque rai che io
per questo episodio ha chiuso qui non
abitazione di girare posto a casa vuoto
camera che comunque sei video è piaciuto
come al solito lo sato commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook come in ogni
video trovate nella descrizione sei o
sette feriti discrete noi ci vediamo un
prossimo vitobello ragazzi